the acquisition annotation and
application of knowledge constitutes
human culture it constitutes human
enterprise we are designed to discover
we are designed to explore according to
some neuroscientists human beings
literally eat information we take in the
majority of our information through the
visual cortex which is connected to
approximately half of our brain
including opioid receptors which means
we get a biological high we get a
biological reward from our brain from
acquiring new interpretable information
we are explorers probing the perimeters
probing the adjacent possible which is
like a shadow from the future that
hovers over the present a map of all the
ways in which the present can reinvent
itself we are curious like nothing else
we are hungry like nothing else
the poet astronomer Carl Sagan famously
said somewhere something incredible is
waiting to be known and this beautifully
and artfully describes our situation our
own awareness that somewhere something
amazing something incredible something
astonishing is just waiting to be
uncovered x marks the spot right and so
human beings are unique in the world
flicked it with this curiosity inflicted
with this wonderment afflicted with this
desire to know
Carl Sagan went further he said we are a
way for the cosmos to know itself f
scott Fitzgerald famously said that when
we went off and discovered the new world
man must have held his breath compelled
into an aesthetic contemplation he
neither understood nor desired face to
face perhaps for the last time in
history with something kamesham n't to
his capacity for wonder but we were
wrong there was more to explore we went
to the new world and now we look to
space and as marina Benjamin world when
we dream of space exploration we dream
of transcendence we dream of what we
might become and so my friends knowledge
defines our condition hunger defines our
situation desire defines our character
the human animal is born to learn
understanding is a kind of ecstasy so
let us not surrender
let us not stop not even for a second
but go forth probe engage acquire
discover knowledge
[Music]